[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to some sub a channel
about how to survive in the online
jungle
my name is bradley and this is a humble
chemistry teacher
walter white aka heisenberg and he's a
terrifying killer and drug dealer
but let's conduct a little thought
experiment what if
walter white had lived in an alternative
reality where bitcoin existed
how would he have laundered his 80
million us dollars
[Music]
so first off we need to calculate how
much money the character walter white
actually had so in the series we see how
he actually buries
eight 55-gallon barrels of hard cash
in the new mexico desert
[Music]
by the way if you enter the exact
coordinates shown in the episode into
your gps
they'll actually point to a film studio
in albuquerque
now this is actually a precaution
against syriza's fans who might decide
to go and look for the treasure
but they'll eventually die in the
vastness of the new mexico desert
now in the series walter white sells
crystal meth for 60 us dollars a gram
this price is quite reasonable
especially for higher quality meth
but how did walter white pile up these
barrels of cash
can you really earn so much money by
selling meth i mean how was the whole
process organized
so there are actually some criminal
experts that watch this series and they
found this model quite realistic
let's actually take a closer look at one
of the trades that takes place in the
fifth season specifically in the episode
hazard pay
white actually sells a 50 pound batch of
top quality blue meth so it's time to
calculate
50 pounds is approximately 22 kilograms
or 22 000 grams
with a price of 60 bucks per gram the
trade brings white
1 million 320 000 u.s dollars
we don't know how many of these trades
he made throughout the five seasons
but the amount of meth we see in the
series is definitely enough to make up
that pile of cash that we see
now in the final episodes of the series
we learned that walter white actually
has a smidgen over about 80 million us
dollars
so when walter begins to earn more and
more cash he realizes that he can't
spend the money without attracting
attention of the irs
so he decides to launder the money but
the traditional approach
doesn't quite work let's see why so when
walter's wife discovers he's become
involved in the drug trade
she volunteers to actually help him
launder this money so this is how
the family acquires a front company a
car wash to be specific
these types of services are widely used
for money laundering probably because of
the correlation between
expenditure and income is less direct
when compared to the production or trade
industries
for example you couldn't exactly use a
car dealer because
they can't sell more cars than they buy
from the manufacturer right
ultimately because the audit will easily
detect fraudulent activity
so long story short any business where
you can over report the transaction
volume
works for a front company now this term
money laundering probably
originated from the american gangster al
capone now this is because the
chicago mafia used to use a network of
laundromats to legalize this illicit
money
hence the term money laundering so
walter and his wife get these car
receipts falsified to make it look like
they had way more customers than they
actually did
then the drug money is deposited to the
bank account as payments for
thousands of car washes that never
actually happened without a large-scale
investigation
no one could ever predict the actual
number of customers that they had
in one episode skyler actually mentions
that the company washes 19 cars per hour
let's calculate how much drug revenue
can actually be laundered through their
sham
business model to find average prices
for car washing in the us
i took into account 2016 statistics and
it's obvious that these numbers aren't
very accurate but
given an approximation they'll give us a
ballpark figure
in the u.s the average price for a car
wash is around 15
so we multiply 19 car washes an hour by
15
and then we get our total of 285 dollars
per hour
so let's assume that said car wash works
from 7 a.m to 11 p.m i.e 16 hours a day
well it gives us around hundred and
sixty dollars per day
to launder so if we work seven days a
week we can assume that over a year
we'll be able to launder around one
million six hundred and sixty four
thousand four hundred us dollars
thank god i'm reading that top of the
screen so as you see here walter had way
too much money to launder through the
car wash
there is no car wash in the world
that could do this kind of business
traditional money laundering schemes
only work to such an extent right
impossible to explain numbers are well
impossible to explain
that's why walter ends up burying his 80
million us dollars
[Music]
now the first bitcoin was mined in 2009.
all five seasons of breaking bad took
place in the early 2000s
when cryptocurrency wasn't exactly
widespread
but what would have happened if walter
decided to launder his
80 million through bitcoin
[Music]
time for a small disclaimer first of all
we're making an unrealistic
assumption that bitcoin would have been
as developed back then
as it is today but it's an alternative
reality you know
and secondly you and i perfectly
understand that crypto is not just for
criminals
statistics show that it's actually
attracting more and more of these
law-abiding citizens
18 of americans have already purchased
crypto
even popular retailers like uh amazon
and starbucks are starting to accept
bitcoin as a payment method
however the decentralized and
semianonymous nature of crypto makes it
really attractive for criminals as well
let me show you a couple of diagrams
by the way guys all of this data is real
and was collected by the world's leading
blockchain analysis firm chanalysis
now the orange colored segments relate
to the volume of illicit money sent
the yellow ones well there for the money
that was received
the red line is the trend now you can
see that between 2017 and 2018 there's
actually a small decrease
in the amount of illicit cryptocurrency
that's being sent and received but in
2019
it's clear that someone added their
barrels full of hard cash into the flow
however illicit financial flows still
make up only a small share of all
cryptocurrency activity at just 1.1
percent
so let's say that walter white digs up
his money he then needs to convert this
whole sum into bitcoins
so how is he going to do this well step
one he needs to buy the bitcoins
the exchange rate for bitcoin is always
fluctuating but let's use the rate of 60
000 us dollars for one bitcoin now
80 million us dollars divided by 60 000
us dollars
only gives us a mere 1 333 bitcoin
by the way the first time someone used
bitcoin as a payment method
was on may the 22nd 2010. in florida
a programmer bought two pizzas for 10
000 bitcoins
if we were to look at today's prices
these would actually be the most
expensive pizzas in the world
11 years down the line the converted
price is just shy of around 600 million
us dollars
now the hitch is that walter wouldn't
risk buying
bitcoins on the exchange directly he'd
probably have to find a private person
or some kind of criminal entity that
needs cash
and that has this 1333 bitcoin in the
bank
now hopefully walters rich vast criminal
networking in the united states of
mexico
would come in handy step two with these
bitcoins in hand
walter has several options first of all
is the crypto exchanges
the diagram on screen shows 2.8 billion
dollars worth of transactions
in bitcoin from criminal entities to
exchanges
now a little more than 50 percent of
these went to the top two
finance and huobi these numbers may
probably come as a surprise
i mean how could finance in uobi the two
largest exchanges
following kyc guidelines received so
many bitcoins
from criminal sources i'll tell you how
now kyc
otherwise known as know your customer is
an obligatory procedure for banks and
exchanges that work with individuals
a person's identity must be verified
before executing a financial transaction
as for our cautious drug lord
well i'm sure that he never worked
directly with the exchanges especially
with those that like to verify
identities
so to whom would he give his 80 million
us dollars
to answer that question let's see who's
standing behind the bank accounts
let's take a look at this diagram these
three columns are of particular interest
to us
now there's actually a small group of
accounts that are harvesting most of the
illicit bitcoin that is being sent to
binance and huobi
the 810 accounts took a total of 819
million
in bitcoin from criminal sources this
represents 75 percent of the total flow
so who are the whales driving this
activity
well they're the so-called otc brokers
or mediators
don't want to be spotted well they'll
help you out
otc stands for over-the-counter and it's
a form of trading in which the seller
and the buyer
deal directly completely bypassing the
exchange
the problem is that while most otc
brokers run these legitimate businesses
some of them actually specialize in
providing well money laundering
and this is all servicing criminals
obviously now the otc brokers usually
have lower kyc requirements than the
exchanges that they're operating on
here's a typical scheme that walter
might be very likely to choose
so starting from the left of this
diagram we can see these funds from a
criminal entity that are moving through
the intermediary wallet
and then to these two otc brokers the
otc brokers then move the funds to huobi
most likely to be converted into cash or
feared oh
by the way fiat is the money that we use
in everyday life for instance
bills coins as well as the funds in bank
accounts these might be in
dollars euros or yan etc the chain
always has numerous links and the money
never goes
from the criminals directly to the
exchanges also
look how many transactions there are
taking place between these accounts
criminals execute multiple transactions
to one another to basically full this
blockchain analysis
another way to cover your tracks is to
use bitcoin mixers people believe that
bitcoin is basically
fully anonymous and untraceable and this
is really far from the truth
i mean yes bitcoin is anonymous unless
someone links your wallet to your name
that's why mixes are widely used and a
mixer
is usually a kind of website or software
that takes in the coins and then mixes
them with many others
and the mechanism here is pretty simple
the site takes in crypto from many
people
and then mixes bitcoins with the help of
algorithms before sending them back to
different wallets
needless to say no one complies with kyc
regulations
and no one requires any documents so
let's move on to the last step
step three now walter white is faced
with a new dilemma
after converting his crypto into fiat
he's got two options
he can a continue covering his tracks
with the help of shell companies
or b find someone who can transfer money
to his bank accounts using
sham contracts for non-existent services
the latter is obviously a bit better now
the main challenge here is to find
service contracts totaling 80 million
[Music]
dollars
[Music]
now felina the last breaking bad episode
is actually called felina
now on top of being an anagram for
finale it's actually an acronym made up
of the chemical elements
fe which is iron li
lithium and na for sodium
now this all together stands for blood
meth and tears which is pretty cool
right
what can the crypto industry do about
otc brokers
and money laundering you might ask why
is money laundering even a problem
it isn't murder or drug dealing is it
well the thing is if criminals had no
chance to withdraw money
and cash out from an illegal activity
then there'd be really
little incentive to commit any crimes at
all which in turn would decrease crime
rates and significantly improve the
reputation of the crypto market
people don't tend to believe that
cryptocurrency is a very regulated space
and there is some truth to that because
most countries
don't have proper policies the necessary
experience or the regulatory tools
however there are still measures in
place to combat money laundering
in the real world banks investigate your
transactions and we can do the same for
virtual ones
i've already showed you how to
investigate blockchain transactions
identify suspicious accounts and collect
data
on money laundering methods meanwhile
exchanges could also investigate their
otc brokers and other agents operating
on their platforms more thoroughly
most major exchanges including huobi and
binance already follow kyc requirements
which is obligatory for most
jurisdictions but let's go back to
walter white
what happened to him did he go to the
bahamas a lie on the beach with a
margarita
well here walter made a critical mistake
one of the otc brokers turned out to
actually be an undercover fbi agents
and this technique is actually quite
popular to solve crimes both in the
world of fiat and
in the crypto world now walter was
imprisoned
but unfortunately he didn't serve his
full time and he got his cancer back
very quickly and died
and by the way if you google
www.savewaterwhite.com
you'll see that walter white has his own
online donation website
and it's still up and running and this
isn't actually a scam
the donate button actually redirects you
to the page of the amc tv channel
this is the one that created this
wonderful and instructive series
the show's creator vince gilligan like
to say if there's a larger lesson to
breaking bad
it's that actions have consequences
[Music]
so
[Music]
you